[Music]
have a feeling we're not in Kansas
anymore
[Music]
we must be over the rainbow
[Music]
how'd you find this place
[Music]
man they got a rope here everything cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
are you serving that ape a martini she's
allowed one it'll calm her down in my
life I have heard many a bizarre story
many a bizarre story containing bizarre
all this happen mm-hmm with luck you've
already brought me the entire 10,000
miles
no only 9,000 891 as the dragon flies
you're amazing
having a luck dragon with you is the
only way to go on a quest things will
work out fine a trail never give up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just do it the only thing I love all
right there it is what do you love I
love poetry and a glass of scotch and of
course my friend Baxter here oh well
guess what now this is happening excuse
me excuse me
what are you doing
awaits me pig
[Applause]
Balram you Wow Ram you till you're a
breed your fleece your clan be true
she'd be true baa Ram ewe
what what did you say I have a plan
you've got a plan I have part of a plan
what percentage of a plane to you have I
don't know
12% 12% it's real totally fake that is
the most real authentic hysterical laugh
of my entire life because that is not a
plan I am Groot so what it's better than
11% what the hell does that have to do
with anything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]